you don't have a title yet and I guess
they don't know who wrote the script
just finished setting up a tripod I'm
gonna record a little bit of our
rehearsal today we are getting ready to
film the very first shaker project in a
long time we stopped making skits in
2014 and in 2014 we announced that we
would make a movie and in 2015 we did
nothing and then 2016 we announced that
we finished the script and then in 2017
we had nothing and in 2018 we said we've
got another script and now we still have
nothing but we have read you had three
scripts yes we do have three scripts but
we haven't actually finished a single
project and that's because we've been
kind of playing the whole studio game
and trying to figure out like if we
could get financing and distribution and
all that like logistical stuff behind
the scenes stuff but we're tired of
waiting and our passion is calling for
us to make something that we can fund
and we can get behind and feel
passionate about and this project I
think really falls in line with JK roots
so when I first met Barton Joe the the
logo for JK was like in an Old English
and like they talked a little funny back
then yeah they don't talk like that no
more but yeah they're a bit more hood
yes
I would say that this project is like
the perfect like homecoming project in
terms of going back to their roots so
and then we went to college and we
learned English so we got better with
our English yeah and I think like the
dynamic that people really love between
Uncle Sam and uncle Chan I feel like
we're bringing that back but in a more
modernized taste of it with like that
the roots that you talked about that's
crazy
and it wasn't we were working on nothing
we were studying because every time we
wrote a script we realised that it
sucked
big time more scripts more than three we
actually have like if you count all of
them it's almost like 10 but it's three
that was completed right and then during
that time we studied our asses off and
every time
made what we're like this is not good
enough and we threw it away this is not
good enough and we threw it away and
then we took classes we dissected books
we had Bible study we went to like
gymnastics class just so we could we
even took karate lessons so I could do
better in the movie and then we got
Steve on board don't even do karate
yeah in this particular project we're
not doing any karate he'll do karate but
it was all for the movie like that's how
serious it was very method of you I also
wanted to take karate anyway me too but
I think they'll go the lesson here is
before I start something new
I gotta realize the amount of work it
takes to do it right because we want to
do it right we don't want to come out
and do it all stupid that's true we want
to do it really good we want to impress
all y'all watching we want you guys to
have a awesome time and go oh this is
like evolution like this is different
this is just a skit that's an hour long
this is something else and it's it's a
game-changer so we're all trying to be
game changers here and it takes time to
master something that's my speech
[Music]
what's the family hello yeah you look
scary from here okay yeah the cameras
all the camera's not adjusting to the
light oh yeah hey why are you still kind
of scary you're like a shadow oh yeah it
looks the way everything looks way
friendlier over here now
friendly Isaac what are you up to jakey
news oh yeah like it's the Wednesday you
know I'm working on you you look busy
yeah I really look that bad no cuz
you're like you look well it's really
hot in here right now
even I'm feeling a little stressed out
now it's really like stuffy why is that
you see now I know that you're working I
don't know why yeah I'm super excited
for this week because we have a guest on
JK Jews here we have to every week yeah
but then this week me I don't want to
make it up too much because you never
know last-minute things I cancelled true
because we have had really big names
scheduled in for news you're gonna be
busy very moving very sorry we've had
really really big comedian names
scheduled for news and then last minute
they'll cancel so too busy for us I'm
not like my hopes up for this one I'm
really excited for this one though yeah
you know what's crazy today though that
we could share on the vlog because I
already showed on my Instagram but a
tattoo artist in Canada last year he
used Gina's face as a reference for a
tattoo and today he posted a tattoo that
he did on someone's arm using my face as
a reference how does that make you feel
being back to you on someone's arm
they're gonna live with your face
forever yeah
that's pretty wild and then the guy that
got the tattoo on his arm here
like that's my arm and I'm like that's
crazy because my face I know I should
have said that just like Oh things are
so honored you have to take but the
artist is so dope because he was able to
like use my my features and like his own
creation of a piece which is really
awesome I'm like wow and then so he I
commented on his page I was like wow I'm
so honored thank you so much and all
this stuff and he was like yeah I did
Gina's last year I'm working my way
through the JK girl that's fine and I
posted in the girl chat I'm like you
girls ready and then people are
commenting is that Casey's arm I'm like
I know right yeah wish it was my arm you
know that I wish but I'm like that's
that's funny that another guy has my
face on his arm so does that make you
feel then I don't know I don't know how
I don't think I processed it like that
like someone else has my wife's face on
there are you I don't like that guy I
don't know if I processed like that like
that yeah you know you know what that
means no that means you're a great wife
and I have no reasons to be jealous so
you think people get jealous because
they don't find loyalty in their partner
I mean no I think it's a territorial
thing you're just not territorial mm
maybe I'm just very sure of myself
sometimes
yeah hype sometimes maybe not I don't
know I feel like you're just kind of
that kid that goes to show-and-tell and
brings a really cool toy and it's like
hey guys look check out my really cool
toy and you're just proud to share it
cuz before I used to make me feel like
dang he doesn't care about me cuz like
do you be like yeah like where's
something really good
and I'm like no but aren't you jealous
of people looking at me and they think
you be like no I mean it's pretty cool
it's like yeah that's my woman yeah it's
like a compliment I don't like I don't
take offense to that but before I used
to think like Danny doesn't care because
it does feel like kinda nice of your
man's a little bit protective of you
but I guess you're just different so I'm
like okay where do other people what
other men do they stand in front of they
stand in between the other guys there's
like the far like on the other end of
the spectrum where it kind of it gets
abusive you know a little scuffle with
the other guys that's pretty extreme but
the middle ground or it's kind of like
hey you say that for me kind of thing I
don't know I don't know I get you I
think the guys would be like that does
it make any sense no I get you
laughs I have stood up for you though
before in the past there's been times
where I'm like oh that's a little out of
line really when yeah um that one time
we're at a concert he stepped on my foot
okay it wasn't like well I was like hey
you should stand back one time we were
walking with your friend Jess and some
guy came up to hit her and it was like
what's up all right that wasn't even me
but she was with us and there was like
our group of friends and I was like hey
she's cool and chill the way she is
right now so we don't need you in our
group right now I don't know I guess
yeah they haven't been placed in a
position where someone was coming at you
like that where I needed to step in yeah
but I get your mentality though because
I remember back in the day when I first
started going around JK and all these
girls would be commenting like oh my god
case he's so cute oh my God he's so hot
and I'd be like yeah that's my man see
see see see what I'm saying I get it
even though back then I didn't make that
correlation between the two things
because I separated them but now that
molds are I could see them it's the same
thing so we get to have each other to
ourselves yep
how about that that's what this is what
oh yeah okay I want that shoe I won't
bother you your desk this is your office
desk
come see me work I'm always in this very
spot true but I mean like that's my desk
I like it I took your pillow actually
what you did that's right you love me so
much you missed me yeah that's how he
knocks on our door every single morning
that's how you make noises like yeah he
makes noises around like harder the cat
yeah knocking like leave us alone does
he ever wake you up no your voice is
getting very deep very deep deeper than
mine really
yeah actually because my voice is
actually pretty high like this okay yeah
like Aziz Ansari hi imagine if I had his
voice persona that's true that's like
the typical like youtuber voice both
have that boy sometimes but now that
we've been just really chill with their
vlogs at home we're just like yeah we
don't need that youtubers yeah we have
we have the Issac voice that yeah moved
in today I mean it's just our normal
voice like a relaxed voice crew
sometimes I rewatched the vlogs and I'm
like man I sound like a mad I don't like
just really chillin that's true it's
like when I see people driving in their
cars on the way home they're not put on
a face to meet people they're just it
looks like they're mad but I'm pretty
sure inside their head they're like
thank God I'm off for time for dinner
and they're looking forward to their
night that's what I like to think so yep
okay you guys hungry
yeah something up real quick and we'll
have dinner soon
something you requested like weeks ago
and I've just been too busy to make I
know what is it chicken Tina I'm getting
editing notes from Isaac what'd you say
all right so you know how you did mm-hmm
so we should do that and then after with
the with we shouldn't do that before
dinner and then we could do and then we
have everything ready I like that so
just do something like this and then it
goes into the cooking process yeah like
this
[Music]
Bon Appetit 150 it's like one for Joe oh
there we go that's the right language
eating tacos yeah
[Music]
[Music]